my favorite things with people are like
dude get a haircut I always feel like
Jim Gordon and Dark Knight
you don't watch a whole lot of news to
you mister but hey we have Mortal Kombat
we know Kombat movie to talk about ID
it's a new movie I almost forgot what
that was like
[Music]
Mortal Kombat legend scorpions revenge
the scorpions revenge is a retelling of
the first Mortal Kombat tournament again
people apparently can't get enough of
the first Mortal Kombat tournament so
now we have the Mortal Kombat tournament
but it's seen through scorpions eyes
he's the main character he's a star
which makes sense cuz let's face it he
was for our childhoods right I mean you
have a specter of death and other people
like of course I played a Scorpio of
course he was my man of course see
what's my favorite I love me some
spectre of death when this thing starts
out man it starts out for those of you
don't know scorpions clan and family
wiped out by the Lin Kuei and yeah that
it's bloody it's savage is tragic and I
love the fact that it you finally see
this in the way it should be seen at one
point you're like hey yeah I I go on a
revenge spree too I know we're all
supposed to be like revenge just not the
way [ __ ] that [ __ ] if you saw what he
saw do you experience what he
experienced I think you totally get why
he's like yeah folks gotta die and the
savagery and the bloody nature of it all
you could tell they were like all right
this is Mortal Kombat blood violence
that was a brick and mortar that that
fighting game series is built on we have
that so we do and I was there for it and
when you actually see him in the nether
room I got some straight-up blood home
and legacy a cane vibe which maybe
that's why I like blood home and legacy
of cane because no legacy a cane gave me
some scorpion vibes and I was there for
the set up I was there for the Mortal
Kombat tournament as long as the Mortal
Kombat tournament felt like the Mortal
Kombat tournament and then at a point it
kind of doesn't I don't know if it's
because this animated movie clocks in at
an hour and 20 minutes which is 20
minutes less than the first movie the
live-action movie but at first it was
like alright everyone gets allocated to
their fights the beams they're
essentially which I enjoy a good
transporting that saves time that's why
they did it in Star Trek but in the
Johnny Cage fight he just ends up
running away the entire time is all
right maybe the next fight the next
couple fights one of them anyway it
ended up being pretty good then the
bloody fashion comes back but the bloody
fashion isn't because it's tournament
now there's a bunch of troops that storm
the place in the leg all right we'll
kill these guys in self-defense still
makes us heroes and I feel like that's
why it happened you look at the roster
and Mortal Kombat most of them are not
murderers if they beat their opponent
Mortal Kombat finish it's like but I
beat them and I'm a good guy
really kill them and most of them can't
die I mean some of them can die but
there would just be a couple tests I
mean come on we need more than two
deaths here this is Mortal Kombat after
all all right we'll just make a bunch of
nameless troops cannon fodder sweet
death so then you get your bloody
fashion but it did compromise what I
feel Mortal Kombat is and what I
personally like about Mortal Kombat I'm
a sucker for a story that adheres to its
own rules and a story with rules one of
the things I love about Mortal Kombat's
the fate of the world but it is a
tournament this tournament does have
rules it's just it was a clever way of
taking a fighting game and giving it a
big story all this is to say Mortal
Kombat 3 was the story that was like all
right no more tournament it's just an
all-out you're defending the realm not
really round one fight though it's still
a fighting game that's what made Mortal
Kombat 3 different this one just kind of
throws the tournament out after a couple
fights and now it's just an onslaught of
people so you have a couple fights hyper
violence just murdering these these
troops that are storming the place which
totally get their decks and then all
right now we're at the end fight it kind
of compromise the feeling of Mortal
Kombat for me I feel like they who made
this animated movie we're like well it's
gonna feel like Mortal Kombat because
death and violence and fatalities and
one might be quick to respond well is
telling the story of scorpions revenge
not necessarily the Mortal Kombat
tournament but not necessarily not
necessarily this movie starts out
setting up the reason of scorpions
revenge by the end does remember that it
is telling that story but for a large
segment around the middle it takes a
spotlight off of scorpion concentrates
more on Luke King Johnny Cage and Sonya
and don't show a lot more of the
tournament so you got a judge on that
too it's a mortal kombat one story with
a lot more scorpion story than we
usually get new Mortal Kombat ones door
so in a world of give and take this
definitely did have some give it had
some tang I thought the violence was
straight-up some bloody satisfaction
that we should have seen it
Mortal Kombat movie before now which we
really haven't it's animation
I thought the animation was great not
only was it great it totally worked with
the style of violence they're going for
and they're telling me one of the more
interesting stories in Mortal Kombat
which is scorpions revenge time so it's
all about what do you want do you want
that or do you want a more cohesive
Mortal Kombat tournament stories if
you're going for that I do think the
movie from the mid-90s is a better
Mortal Kombat tournament story however
for the best telling the definitive
story of all of it yeah the 2011 Mortal
about game that's your path so in the
end I got some bloody satisfaction I
enjoyed it by the end but it does have
some flaws 20 bucks for the blu-ray
might be a little steep I mean the 4k is
like 27 or 28 bucks it'll be 30
after-tax I wouldn't pay that much but I
would say it's still a good time no
alcohol is why you can't rent it right
now but once you can rent it for a few
bucks do that absolutely enjoy some
Mortal Kombat or some Mortal Kombat
legend scorpions revenge have you seen
it what did you think about it whatever
you thought comment below let me know
and as always if you like what you've
seen here and you want to see more click
right here to see more good over
[Music]